I was originally good as this as a talk
and I didn't have the ? all right but
when I decided I'd do it as a workshop I
thought I'd had to add some stuff so
what a difference a question mark makes
so we'll see what it's going to be about
in a minute all right um I guess okay am
I haven't really prepared 524 slides so
don't worry I always like to start with
Dilbert but the idea is if if you want
to interrupt me it's a nice small room
then why don't you do it as we go along
rather than questions at the end okay so
stick your hand up I'll try and give you
a brief answers so we don't go so okay
am and a bit of an acknowledgement and
that's to this guy here called Steven
Johnson he gave the keynote speech two
years ago at euro Syfy in cambridge UK
not cabbage massachusetts and he's also
the guy that's written most of the
connectivity between Julia and Python so
he's now part of Julian computing
because he's another job so I've pinched
a few things from him so if anybody was
at euro Syfy two years ago they can
leave now although there's bits of my
stuff in as well ok um ok so this is a
quick synopsis the first bit is the bit
I've grafted in and that's asking the
question is Julie really fast and if it
is then why is it fast and can you do
the same thing to Python in particular
so can you retrofit the same thing so no
and you can make your own conclusions
i'm not going to tell you what I think
so ok and and then the two bits I was
going to put in the original talk how
does Julia gain from this interaction
with PI 3 and also
can you just get my clock on can you can
you do the same any other any games that
you can make actually from calling Julia
from Python around the other way around
and I'll sketch out what those can be
and so I try and do about 25 minutes the
three workbooks one for each section
I'll try and do about 25 minutes on each
and as I say call me there's only not
many slides ok and so pi think along
with matlab and octave and our have
what's known as the two language problem
which means that you guys all use Python
because it's nice and easy and you like
to type things and you can do it
interactively your data you can
visualize it everything's great however
when it comes to writing critical code
then it's slow really slow in certain
circumstances so you actually have to go
to the API and write code usually in C
or C++ and that's quite rendus there's a
lot of modules so there's a lot of
people done it but so most of numpy
inside p and all those things are
written in c e they're not written so
this is the the two language problem and
the drawbacks are that actually the hard
parts of the code then you'll actually
like to code yourself you're giving
somebody else the opportunity to to
write the code also very often you using
vectorized code which isn't usually that
right sometimes and as I say somebody
else is doing for the program's doing it
even though you guys might be the
analyst so that's the two language
problem and this is Eve
in a super guys so the question is Julia
seems to solve this problem and it does
it by compiling down to machine code and
it's not alone Julie didn't invent LOV m
google v8 is quicker than Julia si Lang
which is the guy who wrote llvm now
works for apple and so in fact most of
the stuff that that you're running on
your apples has been compiled using llvm
rather than GCC swift the nice thing
thing for ipad iphone apps is also done
by the same guy that's using llvm and
lua does a luau jet which is getting
very it for embedded systems why we're
interested in Python developers are
trying to do the same number and
parakeet are actually modules that you
use direct to address your code and say
jitter this piston is a couple of guys
at Dropbox who have decided that they
will write a a complete version of
Python using the Python syntax and they
seem to run out of steam I'm trying to
work tell you why they pull out steam so
if you actually look at the github
postings unless they just had a few
months off they seem to have relaxing
they've done all these e bits okay okay
this is a thing that I guess they
probably wish they hadn't put up but
this is their benchmark so there are a
lot Julia benchmarks but the well-known
benchmark so julia is down the bottom
here I've lost my temper oh wait I'm
tomorrow I'll gunpoint Julia's here okay
I'm and the various benchmarks are here
as you'd imagine for certain things so
here's your v8 okay go for
and the baseline is see okay so pythons
here so it's about 10 to 30 times slower
for toy things mathematica apart from
when you're dealing and matlab apart
from when you're dealing with vectorized
code are is pretty awful you can be
hundreds of times slower you know for
this colony they are relatively do do
well there ty problems so what about
real problems this is from stevens think
and he is an engineer so he's done a lot
of fast fourier transforms and for this
it's not seeing it really okay just keep
pointing and lower is better because
this is in mega flops okay so and then
this way is the size of his FFT that
powers of two so julia is this line here
appears using sim md everybody everybody
know what's mmds sends an instruction
multi data so this actually has got to
data streams for one processor so you're
actually pipe lighting your data in so
these tend to be using cmd these are
which makes this but twice as fast as is
that because you actually your data
pipeline is is the slowest bit
everything else is written in c and
fortran so the question is since Julia
compiles to code why is it faster than
these guys don't hear what I mean it's
not doing any better it's just producing
code as as c compiler a full train
compartment and the answer is that it
uses what's called staged compilation
which means it can make decisions along
the way and we'll see some of that and
actually it can make decisions that a
compiler can't make up the start of your
code so stage compilation putting your
macros new things called generated
functions can actually make it
so so so the prop the answer is probably
when it comes to enterprise computing it
probably is okay and this is the last
slide before we look at some code so why
if you just decide that you're going to
compile your Python code to machine code
isn't that enough and it's because of
some of the original architectural
design features that were put into
Python and that's probably where the
piston guys are having problems so I
want to talk about what's called type
inference type stability once known as
the delegation object-orientation be
chatting to a guy who thought that
inheritance was the only paradigm for
object orientation surely doesn't use
inheritance use a delegation I'll show
what that means multiple dispatch and
then staged code generation so that's
the first workbook so we got time for
some code and I will just make that a
bit bigger risky okay the reason I'm
actually sorry about I guess the reason
i'm looking at work book 3 is because
this is running a Python Colonel I them
to which is actually actually 30 times
faster than Python 3 so if you're into
code however the real reason is because
I didn't want to muck up my installation
by putting part but you can run you can
run both so okay all right we were in a
different life we were talking about
inference and stability and because this
is a because this is a Python Colonel
I'm gonna have to run this so so here is
2 cubed and you get an integer okay is 2
to the minus 3 what you get anybody you
do that isn't good if you try to compile
code that is not good because the
compiler doesn't know what the return
type is all right so that's what time no
what you should do and nobody gets this
right tech square root right oh I'm
sorry I've not Tim don't really I just
not done not done that okay I'd it done
this time take 10 square root and you
get a float tech square root of minus
one you get an error saying invalid
memory matlab doesn't do that it gives
you a complex number so matlab again you
get tapped instability on them and in
fact what you should do is you should
actually take the square root of complex
number to get a complex return time so
don't be got it right python solid pison
doesn't get it right in certain cases
here's another very simple thing it's a
different aspect and somebody tell this
me this was good the fact that that's a
very simplistic definition factorial so
if we take factorial 20 where you get an
integer what happens if we take
factorial 21 anybody come you get along
you get a big int that's not good either
from the point of view of the compiler
as it doesn't know what what types
you're going to return so it has to
allow for both types so let's type
instability now if we're lucky and I
switch tutorials and it doesn't go right
all right ma'am what this is the first
one but it's got a Julia so there I say
the return type of a function should
only depend on its arguments for the
compiler llvm is a very very good
compiler but you've got to give it a
chance all right it's going to stick in
lots of code that you don't really want
if you don't tell it what the types are
so that's
a bit we just run so let's see what
Julia does all right so 2 to the 3 is an
integer 2 to the minus 3 is an error
because you cannot take 2 to the minus 3
and it gives you a bit of a help it
tells you Julie's written in Julia by
and large I did have last time we could
have looked at the code but we're not
going to do that now because we've lost
some time you can go to this and you can
actually look at the line and see which
lines throwing that error in the code
most of Julie's written in Julia okay so
that's an error square root of all is
right square root of minus one is an
error in a different notice these are
actually both in different places and
we've discussed why that is screwed
complex numbers complex here's the
giulio definition the factorial same
definition twenties right what I'm doing
21 I mean anybody what will happen if I
do to anyone yeah and therefore tis
you'd only overflows by one bit you get
a negative number now you might think
it's bad number does that because if
you're going to squeeze in the LLVM
compiler and make it work you've got to
allow yourself overflow that doesn't
mean that you're stuck julie has a
couple of ways first of all it has a big
which will do big arithmetic all the way
secondly it has a if I mean most of the
time you're using big things when you're
doing combinatorics so it actually has a
combinatorics module which is called
factorial if you do that you decide
you're going to use factorial from the
common at orix module then it gives you
it gives you a trap herbal error rather
than just overflowing so there are ways
you can get round it most of the time
why is this important well is if you've
got loop variables which what most
people have I equals 1 to 100 i equals 1
to a thousand Python doesn't know
what type I matter what 12 factorial 21
so it doesn't know whether you're using
an integer a big integer so it can't
stick things in registers okay um all
right I'll go quickly through these so
do this consistent but not necessarily
so for instance if you divide two by
four integers you get a float which is
right but they also means if you divide
four by two you're still going to float
so intuitive vision actually produces a
flipped if there is a a division Julie
you can use extended characters so
that's the same as div so that gives you
a that's how you would get an integer
you can divide two rationals okay and
that the type of the rationals is
irrational you can divide two with the
div and the types and integer so it
isn't that you've got two types you get
the same type it's just you either get
that type or you get an error okay
that's type stability ok and now how
long will get for this one on my on till
quarter past okay quarter past room
right okay well I'd like to go through
the modest but I might leave something
later cuz we lost such a lot time okay
I'm gonna look at go pulling in a module
and for that I'm going to I all right
let's go to the right place okay should
be right put it on twice the load path
here is where its finds modules this
looks a bit weird but actually if you're
a linux guy if you think of all that as
us are then actually it's just because
that's where OSX puts its applications
so it's a USO Julia local or USO Julia
and then it's got site Sam's lot of
things you get pearl so this is a thing
called moderns I can't describe to
quickly because we've lost quite a bit
time but the idea is you've got a
teacher based on a base so so i'm using
13 so you've only got the numbers not to
12 and then when you get 13 that's not
again when you when you get 14 that's
one you so it's actually just it's just
the remainder when you take away the
base these are calm oh god knows what
this is doing but nevermind ok why are
that moved okay so that now this is the
whole module okay we define how do you
negative gate how'd your ad how'd you
subtract how'd you multiply how do you
convert so that if you wanted to add an
integer to a modern and how do you
promote and then this bits just how you
print it out that's the whole module for
modular it okay so here we got three
modular ins or m1 is at eight mod 13 m2
is for mod 13 m 3 is 3 mod 13 so I'm
adding which is in the rules i'm adding
m1 plus m2 times m three anybody can do
that in the head no come on ok 4 3 2 12
plus 8 20 mod 13 is seven ie 20-30 so it
knows how to do that there's an inverse
we can have add an integer we can't add
a rational ok we we can't add a real but
we can we can actually know so all those
is what you'd expect from the module but
now is where it gets interesting I hope
we can produce an array that module
doesn't know anything at all about
arrays but we can produce an array
because the array nose and it so its
delegated the work to the array module
which is what delegation on iOS
it's a given its delegated that and it's
produced an array and we can reshape
their own right we can produce a vector
and we can convo l've the vector with
its with its transpose times the vector
they're right all right we can do that
there's the array and we can map the
cube function to this transpose vector
all right and just to prove its right
you have to look for something you can
as a for here and if you can see that
one so I can do four cubed it's 64 yeah
so 535 13s a 65 so 12 is 64 mod 13 okay
so so yep okay and we can do slices we
take the top corner and remember that
that module was just 13 lines of code
all the heavy lifting is being done
somewhere else so that's what delegation
iOS I'm supposed to be quick but we've
lost quite a lot of time okay the last
thing I want to talk about very quickly
I don't know if I've got to get time to
look at the code is stage generation so
we start with the code we turn it into
what's called asynchronous syntax tree
which is like a lisp code we then add
typed code which means we add what the
types are turned that into intermediate
code and then we compile it now
originally Julia put in macros here at
that stage and then this stage it
compiles into code the new version of
Julia which I've been told number are
doing has an intermediate stage here
which is called generated functions and
the idea is you can generate better
macros if you know what the type cell if
you don't ok so this is a new thing
which actually Julia's given
to python so continuum are looking at
generating code as a way of speeding up
its inversion point five so yeah so you
actually got stage generations here here
and here which is why some of those FFTs
were faster than than some of the
fortran okay just a quick thing let's
have a look just ok so that's the code
it generates for one equals one ok and
not bad this bit here is actually
boilerplate code for the x64 compiler it
just pushes things on the stack so the
actual code is a comparison and then
setting the bit to say whether they're
equal or not and then it pops the thing
off the stack so the actual code which
isn't the overhead is that so if two
lines of machine code for that and this
thing at code night is the is of a macro
so if we look at the Fibonacci series
define the function like the work
because in this case I'm actually saying
this has to be an integer and it has to
be positive so it's a little bit more
that doesn't work either because it's
not an integer macro expansions just
that so it's just pumped in that
boilerplate the code is that ok and I
won't do the rest because what's the
point about that well we can tell the
compiler we're only going to work with
integers we can stick in a macro to kill
catch the integer it can then generate
really tight code this bit up here is
actually just the bit for the assert and
then from down here is the bit for the
comparison so actually we're helping the
compiler ok am I I'll skip the rest and
cuz I got some nice graphics in the next
bit sir
let's go and see if we can catch up a
bit all right um I got two slides which
I do want to show okay all right okay
absolutely two slides and then we got to
some more demo okay so Julia can call
there was an example on here what the
seeds again it could actually call
libraries directly and there is what's
called zero overhead IE just as it was
with the camper you just get a call
statement it calls itself so it's got to
work because if it doesn't work then
okay and then this was an example we
just missed in the previous one it can
also call other languages hiking with a
thing called pi Cole we're going to be
looking up for the rest of the talk this
is the one that Steve Johnson stunned
the work I'm sorry I'm going quickly but
we were up into c plus which is a guy
called keno Fisher simply was is really
hard to interface to Julie ah it's got
two ways of there's an R call and a riff
the difference is riff actually
interfaces to the lib are shared library
so you actually have to build your own
instance with shirred instance to make
it work alcohol in beds and our compiler
in the same way as Java is a jndi
generally and Python embeds so it can
call all those but at present the most
utilized one is Pikul so as I said it
was developed by Steve Johnson it's very
mature works okay it's used in pie plots
which is a rapper a road map la clip
we're going to see some examples in it
symp I which I know is a great got a
nice example of sin PI for you pandas
although julia has data frames but if
you're into pandas you can use and I
think I'll pyl cm which I forgot what it
is but the other thing is that Steve
Johnson went down to Berkeley to
philander /
as lead developer for ipython in a week
they knocked up the julia interface and
that's where Jupiter started so well if
you're not if you don't like sharing
ipython with with Julia and our and lots
of other kernels then blame these two
guys ok all right ok so got some more
some more examples still got screen Wow
gosh this is good okay sorry I'll talk
about what I'm going to do is exercise
these certainly the bits we've missed
and I'll put them onto my github okay
and alright so i'll save that one I
suppose close it and we'll go to the
tutorial too okay so um give you a bit
bigger screen so um so we need pie call
and pipe lot so this is like using
matplotlib to print well see what it
prints sure that's okay so it prints
that okay so so so it's we've written
the code in Julia but we've actually
passed it to plot and we using
matplotlib now some things Julie a
native libraries count doing one of it
yet is 3d graphics matplotlib can do 3d
graphics so let you get so there's some
3d graphics I'm going to skip the which
is a shame i'm going to skip the
database access because he got me to
switch the demon off but this is in my
book I'm not allowed plug in the book
but um I'll just walk you through it now
in Python you would you'd need this
thing alone sequel dock connector you'd
create a connection when the cursor do a
selection execute a query and then close
the cursor and that would show you a
list if you wanted to do that in June
but using Python as the connector then
there's the Julia you import the
connector you do the connection setup
the Serie run the cursor execute the
query print out the list exactly the
same except we've imported the connector
as MC and then we've sort of appended MC
for the connection so actually there's
quite a lot of because we're saying how
nice to you there is no python is nice
to Julia there's quite a lot of stuff
I'm i was at the last thing when we were
talking about MC MC and obviously that's
very slow but you could import that and
run it to the fastest I'll I'll do you
one side pyar I'm going to skip this one
because again we've run out of turn but
this is a least squares fit so that's
Julia that's Julia this bit here is
Python because we're using it we're
using the side pie optimization module
so there's been a Python there okay and
so we've done that and then we can plot
the results and there's the results and
that's matplotlib so that's Python zone
so so essentially what i did was i
generated a sine wave and a little bit
of noise so the blue is the noisy sine
wave the the green near the residual the
noisy points and then the the red is the
fit curve so just quickly go back okay
and I think we can start to slow down a
bit okay so just have a look at that
again on the next okay so right so I
input this that's Julia this is Julia
that's where we call the side pie
optimization kind of course do this in
Julia and then that's where we plot it
using plot which is map so
yeah what does oh ok well it's not
Jupiter pi Cole if I think I understand
it yeah Jupiter Julia like Fortran is
one is base one okay whereas python is
based 0 but Pike Cole converts for you
so an array in Python might work that go
from nought to 19 would convert from one
to 20 yeah so we imported the we
imported with that this one here that
imported the sits I pie optimization
module from the Jupiter Klingon which is
about that bend the rest with the
exception of using that module here and
we also imported pipe lot now that's got
the plotters got put into the main so
you don't have to say p dot plot because
there's only one plot at present so so
that's how it right now it's a bit more
fun there's a this was done in the
google summer of code and it uses a
thing called interact okay and what that
does is this this is all for your Julia
it sort of puts up a widget so you can
you can move through the code here all
right and now it's what we can do is we
can combine interact with pipe lot and
sorry that the wine okay so all right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to generate a plot which
looks like that okay I can change the
heading so i'll say i don't
hello pi I got pinky welcome hi sort of
thing I data London ok it's low because
it's queuing so it depends on quickly
type and we can move the sliders this
this this function was here not function
though which is cause of AX type plus
sine of B X ok and so we could modify
alpha right and then the code changes ok
now our we could modify beta if you do
it and pause in between then it cues ok
so so by combining interact I don't know
if you can do that probably you can do
it in Python let's suppose I'm sure
there are but but well you can do it
that quickly Adam I probably you can
because it's probably written in C ok
I'm so the last one because I won't do
the FX ticker now is one fur on syfy sin
pi and so I just do that I think we get
a pulling in the sin pi so what this is
going to do is it going to differentiate
sine x squared when the star disappears
i'm using the version 3 colonel yeah so
yeah that's it just get rid of that
warning ok so for instance so that is
the third differential of sine x squared
you can prove that because we can go
down to the zero of differential in case
we get inside because quick so so that's
the set first differential second third
ok now up to the 17th differential what
it's done is actually stacked all those
use it using the sim pie and then it's
using the julia latex to
to display it again then it's usually
manipulate to change it as well so by
combining the things that I mean symp
Iser or out a note wrapper around round
the same neck the simple library then
you can produce some quite nice graphics
okay right we're nearly there Wow um so
what I said I wanted to do at the outset
so that's the second book and close that
was oh we go back to the black to him
okay so the question is can can Python
gain anything from interfacing with
Julia obviously julia is gaining quite a
lot I'm interfacing the pine it's a bit
more experimental the guy who supports
it's in Antarctica for six months what
such is open source so I thought that
their connectivity is great in
Antarctica it needs you need to install
pie call and then it's quite easy then
you import and you run a thing there are
some limitations one is that Julia can
support Unicode Python can't so if you
use anything with funny symbols theatres
and alphas and beaters then you're gonna
have a problem and also julia has
remember when we pushed the thing on the
stack we had a thing called push ! is
the kind of convention if you actually
modify any mutable structure you often
put a bang at the end of it just so that
you're showing that you change you
something you shouldn't really be
changing ok so it and again the
exclamation mark isn't a valid Python
identifier so it as a convention so
you can still use it all right em so a
bit more calm it so why would you want
to use Julia well first of all you've
got access to all the base functions
secondly you can implement non
vectorized critical code much quickly
remember that's about 30 or 40 times but
you can do it in a language you can use
and this is you can also pull in
specialist modules like bezan i went to
the previous talk suppose some of you
and we were told that logistic
regression wasn't available in Julia
while it's been available for 18 months
and I had a nice slide which has gone
with the dust but google it you'll find
her julia is about and i think the last
speaker said it took five hundred and
fifty seconds to room Julia it would
take about twenty because it's about 30
times faster okay so so you can use
specially you can interface easily to
see it's got nice and actually one of
the things that's coming is you can run
paralyzed tests tasks so you can get
round the famous global interpreter lock
which gets in the way so those are so
last one and then with tutorial 3 so
what we said is will bring in the Julia
compiler that didn't take long it's
executing this takes a little longer
okay um I think I've got today have I
got yeah I got that running in there I
think soon find out okay um ok so that's
worked so i can combine a bessel
function from julia with a sine function
from numpy okay and yeah so that means
numpy is loaded i can also define a
range and then in Python this tunt
because i'm on the python i can define a
a list comprehension using the gamma
function from Julia okay and which is
done and I can plot it and one of the
strange things about this is that which
I don't really understand is that Julia
when it's using matplotlib puts it into
the Python notebook however look was it
go we should see writing in a gift box i
didn't i didn't win it there we go no I
have to press it at you yeah em so bat
plot lib in probably yeah yeah so but
yeah I mean it there is the funny
function I will try that so presumably
the pie python it interfaces doing that
I guess when it's good it's not being
done okay um right so what else do I
want to tell you um series expansions
can be quite slow let's i'll leave that
i'll leave that this is a module which
i've been involved with its cosmology
the reason i'm going to tell you this is
that it produces the shape of the
universe oh god it is you're right
you're right yeah sorry but let's block
to the thing isn't it this time ghost is
your thank you
alright so whether or not that means
this will come up I do not know okay so
yeah so probably evaluate that then okay
so um so this returns a ship that the
reason I'm showing you this is actually
because we defined the various curvature
matter and radiation densities in terms
of funny symbols sort of latex big Omega
little lambda and so when you look at
the names you can see that they all come
out relatively weird this bit here is
calculated that's the cosmological
constant this bit here is the radiation
density which is also calculated and so
and these are actually the attributes so
I can look at what the Hubble's constant
is because it's h so i can say let's
have a look at all the Hubble constant
isn't it however I cannot look at what
these are because the way we wrote the
module is using symbol deland to load on
the interface whether that gets changed
is not indifferent and the rest of it I
think I'll leave or to just freakin
money to guess the age of the universe
for this particular universe 14 billion
years oh yeah this one's quite
interesting if I want to pass if I want
to pass the thing I actually have to
store a number on the julius side and
because i want to print it i also store
it on the python side that's the
redshift so so r SJ is on the julius
side and I've kept that an RSP so then I
can actually call that with our SJ here
in the Julia argument and I can print it
with RSP here so you have to do both and
then you get the angular diameter is
nearly 2,000 megaparsecs is a 30-percent
redshift ok so that's so those are the
very last
thing I'd like to do is a nation options
now this i have a python one that's
ended and that you can run it in Python
max set it up well so the idea is this
is that it's loopy and you can't really
do it any other way than being loopy
what we're going to do is we are going
to generate a lot around the numbers
we're going to do some tracks and then
we're going to store all those and we're
going to take the mean and if if the
means before what we pay then we will
add that otherwise it will work at the
option price so that's evaluated and so
if I time that ok so it took one point
the option price is one point six eight
pence put for a pound and it took 30 3.2
seconds to do one two three four five
six so what's that hundred thousand six
knots roots a million million okay so i
took we're ok now let me just quickly
and then we finished pretty well i just
got to do wind up I need to I need a
another shell had the other shells cross
change two notebooks / pi d / code okay
um a bit bigger so this is this is some
of the code that sinners in the get one
of the things here is my version of was
it the asian option in python okay just
to prove its true it's a bit more okay
so it's pretty much the same code okay a
bit of a loop okay if i run that
ok
no doesn't they like long just take a
while there we go same solid price how
many seconds mm-hmm no I should have
timed it so what did time it turn tickle
a while again
so remember the Julia was what 3.5
seconds there we go 21 seconds seven
times faster yeah I have it's it's only
a ten-thousand-dollar hundred thousand
not a million so that is actually
seventy times slower not seven so that's
one of the advantages you would get for
interfacing slow code written in Julia
to python 77 no now you're actually just
embedding the Julia compiler you know so
and then you what you've actually got to
do is make sure that all the code is
actually run and that's what you have to
do with MC MC or something like this to
get you know so if you were doing the
logistic regression you try and use a
module and actually fill in all the code
if you actually do bits then the bits in
between are going to be slow because the
Python interpreter so don't you do your
loops in Python okay all right so we're
done i think i just put it the last two
slides and okay so okay so summing up it
may be that speeding up python using
will not work you may not agree with
that that's way back before the display
disappeared okay mainly because of type
inference and type stability and i think
that's why the piston guys are in
problems they have to a dear to all they
want to adhere to some of the the
architectural features of python that
maybe maybe I like will that work
doesn't mean at all because obviously
number does it this Graham will tell you
but probably doesn't do it to the kind
of speed we want Python actually has
established a niche domain I mean
they're not putting it on this BBC yeah
it's a nice study it's really moved
basic out of the way as a nice starter
language why kids are learning the
school-wide
journalist who years ago it probably I
think it's better than its nestor but
you know these are all and from the
Julia point of view python is very very
valuable as a tool but i hope that i
showed you that there are areas where
you could get away with thee if you're
doing yourself you could get away with
the sea dependencies and a news pythons
Ted to actually profile your code say
ninety five percent of my codes being
written this I'll write our writer
module in Julia and then I'll just
interface using pi Julia as an interface
and then there's some references here
actually it's a shame because I'm um so
these are on the thing the interesting
too and I think that's the last slide
yeah the interesting two of these to
Quantico net is an economics thing done
by John Sargent who's a a Nobel Prize
winner in economics which isn't hard I
think there's only about 70 comments so
they take it in turns winning the Nobel
pro but actually that's interesting
because he actually has all the code
written Julia and all the code written
in Python so they've got the whole
double branch and they have just done a
thing with the New York Stock Exchange
to move the dsge which is written in
MATLAB to Julia so that is probably the
first Enterprise thing and if I had
still got the connectivity I'd show you
the the paper but they were so so in
fact Julia probably will oust matlab
quite soon well it so stood it in the
New York Stock Exchange they are cost
your money have you always look to the
cost of a license to like that okay and
then that's it thank you
thank you very much likes questions yeah
yeah I'd not sure we got that long but
yes you know we do that's right yeah
yeah yeah 35 minutes I thought I just
wander past sorry that yeah as in this
is where you'd finish the presentation
and then you have room for questions it
being a tutorial oh and I'm happy to do
questions I just got a bit slower I've
run I've missed a few things so well
especially since we're especially since
we had the 20 minutes of can't get my
screen to work so anybody got any
questions yep I mean do you think what's
then what's the reason you ah like
that's an interesting question because I
would say once you start using Julia for
you probably would say let's do it all
in Julia yeah however you know it may
well be that you've got a big Python and
you just profile it you find you've got
something you know that you want to do
within a Python situation but you still
want to get but like an options or well
you're the other way you can do in Julia
you if you actually try and use the
Python API to write see it's pretty
horrific because you've got the sea call
you get what you can do because we've
done this is you can write some see
compile it to a shared library and then
you can just interface from Julia with
the sea call to the to the see you've
written not using the PI object pie
python api so actually can write you see
as you were to write it in a sea program
or you could interface to let's say
you've got a specialist library that I
don't know makes arms gotten down on
widgets move around you can interface to
that just by doing wrappers around the
code whereas I don't you ever write any
em ap I see it stuff in party okay well
there you a clever guy yeah clever guy
anybody else yep
no I i I've seen any integrate now I am
wet yes yes and then again its shape yes
there are modules there's a group one of
the guys viral sure who's one of the
original three runs a group in bangalore
that's looking at all the connectivity
there are rappers for Hadoop and 4 z
Khan y'all the second month the yeah so
there is a rapper for that you can do
that I think there's a spark however the
the paradigm for parallelism and julia
is different from Hadoop doesn't run on
the JVM and it's different from message
passing MPI there are modules that will
do that and what it uses it uses ship
should run time distributed runtime
procedures ok so and it uses macros so
that you stop sit out paralyzing if
you're lucky the whole thing just gets
moved to all you could so uses a third
paradigm ok what's probably more
exciting to me is that the new version
is looking at shared memory access a
rewriting of distributed arrays and
therefore you'll get genuine threading
and that should be really quick so
that's why they keep rewriting it we are
promised we'll get 1.0 by this time next
year which is the next year Leah
conference and they've formed a company
so they want to make money now are
actually they're making money i mean
they're getting money from New York
Stock Exchange anyway so so they are but
they're making some big architectural
changes on but so they have yeah yeah
Betty Moore is it terminal six or eight
thousand dollars they give large chunks
of money software to the celery
and things of that nature so Julia 108
hundred-thousand-dollar about 6mm about
600 thing yeah why did you make it
around million I have no idea well yeah
well actually there's five guys now
working for julia computing the original
three plus kina Fisher who wrote that
and a guy caught and Steve Johnson but
there's actually a lot of other people
we've got four people over here actually
actually working from Simon Byrne who is
speaking it I believe okay so he's and
he runs a lot of Julia stats so all this
nonlinear realistic regression well he's
probably speaking on them yeah how does
that Alex and Gupta and my Guinness so
there's the three or four people
actually employed by Julie computer in
the UK but but the inner core of five
people so the original three developers
are all still working for julia
computing which is probably good and
actually that's one of the problems you
get there's been a few things where they
started and then it's died because the
developers were to make money and go and
do something else really had to pay the
bills okay don't got time for one more
if there it's in one more oh yeah which
constructs make compilers work faster or
Jerry to agreement forward hmm is proper
type annotation see yep yeah turn which
is what we did for the Fibonacci one yet
she said it's an integer and block it if
it isn't you they can siphon eyes it
baggio big speed up from annotate or
representation for things like number
it's going to try and do that sort how I
the word try I'll i do i'd try because
it has to be yeah yeah yeah i loved ones
rice what never says ojala go home so
what does julia offer well in that suit
okay well well it was easy I mean as a
person who what's a only knows the Julie
all I had to do was colon colon integer
and that was at a conference and I had
to put in a certain to say make sure
that and that was a macro that did the
check exactly so
I can if you actually look at proper
modules which are all online you will
find most of those are actually typed
rather than on tight so you know but on
type code when you generate it as as
boxing and unboxing code for shifting
around because it doesn't know so
obviously is quicker new generates which
by above factor of three often you know
so see you might generate 20 lines of
code instead of 60 but I just think it's
easier I mean to the analyst who doesn't
want to get into the technicalities then
you just you just say colon colon and
put the typing and then the compiler
will cough if you if it don't like it
like this factor is lovely news what we
doing it's really right how nice this
nitrous yeah well its got ir trace oh
yeah where you can go to the thing you
yeah yeah well you can actually go to
the line and add the repple not not I
not Jupiter but the repple actually is
bone so you can actually press a key in
then it goes into the editor and you can
find the line so but that's in the
command the repple it doesn't work
there's a few things that don't work in
like you can't you can't shell to the
operating system or a file completion
what you're getting the repple but you
don't get enough okay sorry guys that
it's run over but I will ya ya see any
on your burning questions or if you
decide to make it your mission this
weekend to learn jr. that's easy it's
deceptively dis no it's just easy not
deceptive i deceptive look ok then
you'll be around well d OS okay so thank
you very much everyone and then we'll
break lunch just a quick thing I will if
anybody wrote down the thing what I will
do as I say as I will fill in the bits
that we didn't do some of those like the
interactive won't work because it won't
store and then I will push those
notebooks on to the same good get up in
a subdirectory called worked examples
and I'll also change the readme to point
to the slides which are on thinking flax